all right if we get some rain that might
make a lot of people happy i'd love it
water my lawn for free yours too our
skies have been cloudy overnight and
early this morning sun is up so we've
got some light out there it's just not
sunny it's kind of muggy we've had some
threatening rain cells off to the east
side but they've really weakened a lot
by the time they've gotten over here to
the valley 86 degrees 80s all across the
valley this morning and it's pretty
humid 33 percent with the dew points
they've even risen a little bit into the
mid 50s so sunrise was 6 12 709 is the
sunset outside the valley it's been
pretty warm too indian springs just
barely below 80 degrees 84 in param
clear skies make a real difference of
letting the warmth escape so when you're
cloudy it keeps the warmth in mid 80s
mesquite and laughlin this morning 98
out in death valley 69 up in caliani ely
at 52
smoky of course up in northern and
western nevada 57 in reno right now
there are still air quality advisories
across many areas of the west with
wildfire smoke and all those areas of
green those are flash flood watches as
we're looking for monsoon thunderstorms
today and all of these areas of green of
course keeping an eye out for the
remnants of ida now a tropical
depression of course it's left so much
flooding behind in louisiana mississippi
and is sending more rain up into
tennessee
power outages galore behind it and more
rain will continue right up towards the
northeast where all those flash flood
watches are posted and have been issued
getting over to the calder fire now
again evacuations yesterday of south
lake tahoe all these areas down along
u.s highway 50 highways 89 88 i mean it
is just really sad to see how this fire
is growing and is chewing through so
many areas cabins were burned or echo
summit folks evacuated around kirkwood
the beautiful ski resort there and of
course over to gardnerville
people have set up evacuation centers
there and soon there may be areas there
evacuated as well as the calder fire
keeps growing back here at home remnants
of nora feeding into the monsoon
pipeline and that's going to help
trigger more showers and thunderstorms
i'm seeing heavier ones down now around
the arizona mexico border though again
we've seen some cells pop up still a
little green on the radar it looks like
something trying to form over mount
charleston right now so embedded
thunderstorms today and some of those
could drop some very heavy rainfall
we're looking at the possibility of
lightning expected with these cells as
well as some very strong outflow winds
so it could be damaging today please be
careful outdoors and watch these storms
tomorrow still a 20 chance of
thunderstorms we'll drop to the 90s for
a few days and we'll enjoy that and then
a little warmer for the weekend a slight
chance of thunderstorms again on labor
day